so like what's the deal with senior
software engineers hey everybody my name
is miyuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about tech career and life
so thanks to a year-end survey that i
did last year as well as me looking at
my analytics all the freaking time i
know that a lot of y'all are university
students studying computer science or
similar to get into the tech industry or
you're doing a career switch into
software engineering or you're an early
career software engineer and you're here
for fun times and advice and career and
stuff like that that means that you'll
probably feel something when i say the
term seeing your software engineer and
that's probably because a lot of you
have been through the whole like
software engineering job search in a
while and you see that like most job
postings out there for software
engineers are prefixed with the word
senior to the point where it almost
feels like companies are only ever
hiring for senior ones and you know what
i've had thoughts about this in the past
like why don't companies hire more
junior engineers like what even is the
big deal with seniors why is senior such
a loaded term and why do companies want
them so badly so when i'm feeling kind
of like the like frustrated like oh like
i don't get it about something i talk to
somebody about it so i talked to my
friend sophie who's the ceo at
formation.dev about what does it mean
what is a senior software engineer her
company is actually the sponsor of
today's video so thank you to
information for sponsoring stick around
to the end to learn about how they take
junior and mid-level engineers to land
jobs at fan companies so let's define it
what does senior software engineer
really mean to me like the one word that
i would
really associate with seniority is
ultimately impact like how much impact
are you having as as an engineer right
so you start off in your career you're
working on like little tasks right like
very isolated pieces of code that you're
you're shipping and over time you're
increasing your impact both in terms of
scope of the the feature or the product
and impact on the team i think seniority
comes in so many different shapes and
forms so i actually encourage people not
to think so binary
when it comes to you know i'm either a
senior software engineer or not like
there's so many different levels above
and there's so many ways that you can be
senior this totally checks out with my
experience of being a senior software
engineer because yes i am a senior
software engineer as soon as i got the
promotion or like the role of senior
software engineer uh even maybe even
like a couple months before that because
i had to be promoted into the role which
means i had to already be doing this i
just was trusted with a lot more surface
area in the code base in fact my very
first senior software engineer role was
at patreon where literally i was the
only ios developer at the company and so
i owned the entire ios code base which
is a lot so yes i definitely had a lot
of impact in the work that i was doing
because i was literally the only one
doing it don't worry we did hire other
ios engineers afterwards it was just
like a short year where like i was the
only one and it was kind of hard but
help me grow but even with this whole
definition of what a senior software
engineer was i still feel like i have
this like
frustration towards like this whole
senior thing to the point it just felt
like it was kind of almost like a
gatekeeping mechanism sort of
especially because i heard of like so
many great and incredible efforts all
across the industry to invite people
from underrepresented backgrounds into
tech like all these efforts to invite
women into tech or veterans into tech or
just like how computer science programs
at universities are so incredibly
impacted and full that it's like busting
at the seams
but let me tell you when i was like
senior software engineer i was like cool
where are they where like i don't i
don't see any of them like i don't get
to work with junior engineers so like
where where are all these people i just
thought maybe senior software engineer
was just like a really elusive term that
prevented people from like climbing the
ranks in tech or something like that
like i think it was that whole like oh
in order to get this job as a junior
engineer you had to already have two to
three years of experience kind of crap
so i just thought something similar to
that was happening with the whole senior
software engineer situation i do think
that the title
senior software engineer is somewhat
misused in a lot of like smaller
companies in particular especially ones
that don't come from the traditional
tech industry where they're almost using
it as a word to like attract people
because they're like oh call you a
senior engineer you know at least from
you know at facebook and at next door
where i worked like each of the
different quite granular levels again
meant something in particular that is
specific to your responsibilities and a
pretty well-defined scope of work and i
think internally it is much more clear
with a lot of interns and with a lot of
super junior engineers who are just
graduating from boot camps the
expectation to be honest
for someone that junior is that they're
net zero in terms of like effort to
train them
and like how much output they're gonna
get engineering is one of those things
you're not typing a whole lot throughout
the day like you're only writing like
tens of lines of code maybe and so it's
all in the thinking right and so if
you're at a point where you don't know
what to do and you need someone to think
through it and help you figure out the
solution
then you know it would be faster
typically for that person to just do it
and rather than explain it to you and
the only work that you're able to save
is like maybe the like the the minor
amount needed to like type up the
solution and send out a change or
something like that so when you're
really really junior when when when a
company is hiring you and you know i i
see this with some of our junior hires
too is that i'm investing in this person
right i believe that this trajectory of
this person is so high that in a year
when they're very net positive i want
them to already be on our team really i
think when some companies say senior
what that signals to me is that they
don't have the capacity right now to
have a net zero or
oftentimes even net slightly negative
because it takes more effort to train
them than the output this is where you
really have to remember that like
companies at the end of the day are
businesses so they operate by using
their resources wisely in order to
generate revenue and at a typical tech
company employees like people are by far
their like biggest most expensive
resource so every hiring decision has a
lot to do with what does the company get
out of it versus what does the person
get out of it and making sure it makes
sense and it took me a long time to like
really internalize this because i fought
this for a long time but literally some
companies just don't have the time or
money or bandwidth in order to train
junior engineers to become senior ones
that's typically why you don't find
junior roles at startups because they're
literally just hauling ass trying to
like make product
i think a lot of the impact
that seniority levels within
a huge company
relates to
the number of engineers that you your
work has an impact on right so when you
ship a small feature like you're only
impacting like your immediate team right
and over time you're growing in scale in
terms of the amount of impact to you
know now your code is impacting tens of
engineers hundreds of engineers
thousands of engineers the whole company
right i think that it's possible that at
smaller companies it's actually very
hard to have those different tiers where
it's like you know there's not like
those more different levels of scale
because within at least the facebook
hierarchy there's at least like six or
seven pretty distinct
categories that i can think of that each
of them means something quite different
in terms of like your your scale of
impact but a lot of the scales of impact
actually just don't translate or make
much sense in a smaller company setting
this is just how companies work so in
order to be employed by them you kind of
just got to keep this value exchange in
mind so since a lot of companies don't
have the time and resources in order to
train juniors to become seniors there
are things that you can do in order to
fill your own skill gaps things like
becoming proficient in your technology
or your programming language or working
on your problem solving skills i think
becoming proficient in project
management is also a part of this too
and really just learning how to be
resourceful on your own so learning how
to figure out problems without much
guidance without much hand-holding i
think is one big differentiating factor
between junior engineers and senior ones
and it's a learned skill
so all that said like when do you know
when you're a senior software engineer
like how do you know that you can like
apply to those roles or like maybe even
put that title in your linkedin i think
to me the answer is when you own
some small area of the product and you
are the go-to person for something in
the company at the facebook level like a
small area of the the product might be
something like you know the bookmarks at
that on the home page like if you own
that whole area and if anyone in the
company's like there's a bug in this
this area um like you're the go-to
person then then you're probably a
senior engineer so there is kind of a
sense like someone has to call you a
senior software engineer before you can
call yourself one i think it's like a
you'll know when you know kind of thing
which is like
again frustrating i know but it does
kind of just happen i guess because the
really important part is that in order
to be called this i think your
performance and your impact have to be
objectively evaluated which it's really
hard to objectively evaluate your own
stuff so that's a low down on senior
software engineers am i still a little
frustrated about the whole thing yes of
course do i wish there were more
companies that actually hired junior
engineers and trained them to become
senior engineers because it would be an
investment toward their future and the
industry's future of course but this is
what we're working with and i think it's
important to know what's going on in
order to like know how to like become a
senior software engineer basically in
one really really great way in order to
level up your skills to become that
senior software engineer is to check out
the formation fellowship information is
the sponsor of today's video and they
have a really unique program that's
helped engineers to land jobs at
companies like facebook and google and
lyft and twitch and airbnb so thank you
so much to sophie for being in today's
video and sharing her insight she's the
ceo of formation actually and she knows
a lot about the whole software
engineering interview process and how to
level up information was founded by
staff level engineers like sophie and
others from companies like facebook and
nextdoor who conducted thousands of
software engineering interviews and
wanted to help prepare software
engineers to perform at a fan level bar
for those interviews you can apply to
their fellowship through their website
formation.dev if you identify as someone
who is an engineer with one to four
years of experience who are focused on
front end backend or full stack and need
help training for technical interviews
once you get accepted into the program
you get a training plan that's
personalized to your specific skill gaps
with direct mentorship from super senior
engineers and referrals directly into
the top companies in the industry the
fellowship usually lasts between three
to six months and once accepted they
support you unconditionally until you
land your dream role of course you can
do this part-time if you're currently
working they also offer income sharing
as an option so if you want you can pay
nothing until you get a job i mean you
all know interview prep and like
technical interview studying and stuff
can be so just mind draining and stuff
like that and so having a program like
this that's structured with advice from
people who are really experienced within
the industry can really improve your
odds of landing your dream job you can
apply for free on their website at
formation.dev which is linked also in
the description box and whether or not
you get in you'll get some invaluable
career advice from an engineering mentor
and a free prep guide that's a really
helpful resource to prepare you for fan
level interviews thank you so much
information for sponsoring thank you
sophie for being in the video and thank
you for watching don't forget to
subscribe and let me know what you
thought in the comments down below i'll
see you next time bye
[Music]